comment ça se passe la pandémie chez
vous ça se passe relativement bien
on a mis du femmes sous nos jours on
passe beaucoup sans l'extérieur on passe
beaucoup de temps prend soin de notre
environnement
puis je pense que ça ça nous enlève un
peu de la zone dense y était ambiante
que ce que vivent certains de mes amis à
montréal et beaucoup de gens que je
connais aussi fait je me sens prêt à
l'appui de salle attenante
[Musique]
le coroner virus a quand même contre
karim au plan artistique parce que vous
avez un nouvel album qui vraiment super
bon mais vous avez dû annuler les
spectacles comment vous vu elles sont je
le vis très bien parce que voilà je
pensais c'est simple problème de
privilégiés qu'il me plaît je fais pas
de spectacle alors que que j'ai des
économies que je suis capable que je
suis en santé que tout va très bientôt
chaque jour je trouve ça triste pour la
vie de l'album mais en même temps je me
dis que quand même c'est pas du jeu
james et mieux pas penser au fait que
peut-être qu'ils qui est mort
prématurément que ça qui va avoir la vie
difficile parce que ces chansons là
existe depuis hakim instant quand même
bien après tout ça
c'est votre quatrième et vous célébrer
vos dix ans de carrière cette année je
sens chez voir un désir de vous
réinventez est ce que léon solution à un
alex nevsky beaucoup plus posé un peu
moins festif en poids il a changé sur
alex nevsky au fil des ans
ben vous mentirai pas en disant que je
me couche à 8h45
donc je suis même pas les dents les
facetime de grue avec les amis ne passe
que me suis déjà couché donc c est ce
qui a changé quand même ça change
beaucoup la peut-être la première année
avec un enfant ça change un peu la
vitalité
je dois on est fatigué souvent vissé cc
autant autant c'est extrêmement nourris
cinq ans parce que pour moi qui avais qu
il y avait ce désir extrêmement présent
avec ma fille puis ma blonde je m'étais
pas mis beaucoup d'énergie dans la
création d'un team
dans la cité
sachez que quand je faisais des chansons
je suis dans un essaim aussi facilité on
est en studio je prenais trois cafés par
jour ce n'est pas aussi plus qu le même
alex qui l'emmène vers les pics lève à
minuit qui quittent chez les chansons
jusqu'à 3 heures du matin si le à 5h en
puncheur out le studio je m'en allais à
la maison donc je pense oui c'est
forcément ça fait un album qui est très
différent parce que je veux plus faire
semblant d'avoir réuni dix ans j'ai
vraiment préféré s'affairer les bons
souvenirs parce qu'on a parlé de moody's
ans de carrière sur la voie
saucisse a vraiment changé la donne pour
voir quelques wii après c'est sûr que de
devenir coach de l'as de la vraie voie
après levi deux autres pôles de la
région ça va changer quelque chose dans
le regard des gens mais c'est sûr que
c'est positif mais je pense qu est ce
qui reste beaucoup de ceux c'est que je
suis je suis plus une levée des chèques
sans amener des gens dormi salle mais je
peux pas je peux pas dire quel point ç'a
changé mon rapport à la vraie vie chez
chose certaine en ce moment je suis très
heureux d'être à la maison puis de
jusqu'à sa a été officialisée que que
j'étais pas présent à la cette saison je
suis allé au restaurant que je me
sentais déjà moins observé où je me
sentais déjà que je pouvais me comporter
d'une façon plus l'os plus normal c'est
un poids que j'ai envie de me disais pas
ça fait ça fait vendre
[Musique]
doucet
saleh
qui est le plus précieux conseils que
vous avez reçue c'est moi le meilleur
conseil que j'ai reçu de la part de de
mon ami yann perreau qui m'a dit tu
devrais vraiment mettre des refrains des
chansons parce qu'au début je voulais je
voulais pas ma fille russie
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
même je me souviens d'une conversation
avec ma mère nous dans nos trois ennemis
sur marsan où je disais je pense que je
vais pas mettre les coloris et non leur
a fait croire sur l'album je trouve que
c'est vraiment trop comme au plavix et
parce que je te projeter j'ai envie
d'être un artiste plus profond qu'il a
m'avait convaincu dit m c'est ce qui m'a
qui m'a complètement sauvé la vie parce
que sinon je sais que je le suis
j'apprends chaque jour encore alex
nevsky merci mille fois merci nos
couleurs
[Applaudissements]